basically at about 24 months here here's
where she started grabbing the the tutus
and the dresses by three and a half
Kieran she started grabbing them like
you didn't put them on her on him you
didn't start like handing them and be
like does this look nice to you he just
grabbed a little kid just grabbed
something that was bright and fluffy
looking like he would have stuffed
animal and even if he put it on that
doesn't mean that he identified as a
girl like this is parents being crazy
and aren't they the same ones that say
like gender shouldn't be confined or
like be synonymous with certain objects
so like if this kid was grabbing tutus
what in your mind why would that make
him a girl a half Kieran had
transitioned to a girl today she's nine
years old a third grader and an athlete
that's why the clawsons are celebrating
Governor Holcomb's decision to veto a
bill that would have banned Kieran and
other transgender girls from playing on
girls sports teams at school there were
okay up until the age of nine or ten
then it's okay for them to play yeah
because I had girls playing on the boys
teams when there's no checking that's
like the thing like you're not even old
enough to hit yet yeah I was playing
hockey and you couldn't even hit the
other people so that's why there was
girls on the team so yeah that's normal
for like nine right and there weren't
that many girls on the TV wait there
were girls no but that's a guy on the I
mean I don't know because like it wasn't
guys going into girls leagues it was
girls that were good going into guys
leagues so I still think that's actually
kind of weird right now but the I think
it's fine when there's no checking
involved it was really about stick hand
we're talking about I saw nine it's like
ice hockey we were talking about stick
handling and skating ability at that
point you know speed was a factor but it
wasn't like the way it becomes after the
age of 10 11 12 and there's a real
differential well girls actually
developed earlier so like some of the
girls would be smoking the boys because
they're like at like that age they're
like typically taller than boys oh right
right then they go in completely
Divergent paths so yeah you can let your
nine-year-old boy play on the girls team
but does he belong in the girl's locker
room like what's wrong with these people
like this is so sad that a parent would
want this and push this on their child
look at the sign they have too stop a
trend stop attacking our trans youth
imagine you had that in your house
throwing up as a kid for like what you
identify as that just like it's just
victim mentality to the max like every
time you go out you're like every time
you wake up in the morning that's what
you see like I'm a victim and like
people don't like me every single day
that's what they see how does that not
have a subconscious effect on you when I
told Kieran she squealed with Glee there
are people watching this right now who
will say people who were you could tell
a little kid anything and they'd squeal
with Glee well when you've told a child
that you're a victim you're a victim
you're a victim you're a victim oh the
governor is Gonna Save You Now
you know what I mean like like they have
this kid and this horrible heavy adult
themes instead of letting it just be a
kid people who were born and are living
life as a girl are biologically
different so it it places it places them
in an unfair Advantage my daughter
your son will never go through Mayo
puberty he says Kieran will undergo
hormone therapy to make her no different
than any other girl Mike except she
doesn't have ovaries and she's not an
actual girl I mean this is just absurd
but I do agree like yeah obviously it's
different in sports when the kid starts
at age three compared to like 20 after
they went through male puberty like I
get that I'm not like I'm a logical
person but I still think that there
should be a line cross and I don't think
that they should be in the same sport
they do not know enough about these
puberty blocks I think that's just like
insane that you would ever do it like
that that we shouldn't even be talking
about the sports thing we should be
talking about why you're not in jail for
doing that planning puberty blockers for
your three-year-old that's absurd that
is absurd you could have done that to me
you literally could have done that to me
and I would have had no say in it my
whole life you would have been like yes
this is why what I want to do my whole
life like this kid it's a new
Consciousness and this is their new
reality because of the parent not
because of them they weren't born that
way that's not true I don't buy it man
that's remember when when we
did the whole bathroom over and
SpongeBob stuff and SpongeBob towels and
SpongeBob shower curtain and everything
first I remember yeah right could I
forget you still want SpongeBob all over
the place well well kinda actually but
yeah maybe not
but we don't have SpongeBob all over the
place no I know you grew up and you
changed but if I yes what we're going to
do is I was amped I was pumped when I
saw SpongeBob curtains in my bathroom I
was pumped a kid's Mental Health
is more important than your kids trophy
said the kids mental health is more
important than my kids mental health is
more important than your trophy so this
other child's right to achieve under
Fair circumstances does not matter
and don't tell me that you are actually
doing anything for your child's mental
health because every study shows that
this is not healthy for a person's
mental health every single one so this
guy is just full of and he just
wants to have a freak child so that he
can feel special because he's not
special this is Munchausen by proxy is
what this is it's crazy because he looks
like a based guy like he looks like a
normal based guy but like this one
doesn't look at his shirt our daughter
is 10 years old
um she started letting us know that
um she was transgender really
um before she could even speak she would
do things like where her sister's
clothes
um pretend that towels were her long
hair and when she was about three years
old she started to withdraw and become
depressed so we started doing some
research we talked to her pediatrician
our daughter is 10 years old
oh my god there was so much wrong with
what they just said that's insane where
do you want to start we can start at the
kid was wearing his sister's dresses and
putting a towel on his head a little kid
was like that's not like normal I'm sure
dress up kids play dress up that's what
they do I could have done that and I
would I wouldn't I don't remember but
like I'm sure I might have I never
remember we were always like playing and
goofing around and then the kid became
depressed what do you mean the kid
became depressed it's a three-year-old
how do you become depressed as a
three-year-old
um I usually listen I am I am no
psychologist I do not know but bro the
lay person in me knows that children can
become withdrawn and after a trauma so
is there something else that happened
here that they're not telling us a
three-year-old being depressed your your
solution should never be that it's
because they're they think they're the
other gender like that is the that's the
last thing I would ever possibly imagine
for why my kid is up same on these
things the last thing because and you
know what it's like to be a little kid
your reality is so different from what
it is now like your brain I'm disgusted
analyzes the world completely
differently so to think that because
you're 40 and you believe this
that that's where your kid's head is
they don't know anything they don't know
anything a kid that age she's talking
too doesn't even know the difference
between the hot faucet and the cold
faucet and how to not burn itself when
it watches what if or how to even wash
its own hands you think Santa's real too
you're like hey that's or older if
you're lucky three times longer than
this little has been alive but this
child is a little little boy at two
years old thought that he was Marilyn
Monroe I call everyone I buy it I call
everyone little my cousins call me
little don't get so upset because
I'm sure they're watching me about
racism anti-blackness or violence
this guy likes it in the butt
stupid thing to say I will use my voice
in the most uplifting way possible
and do everything in my power to educate
my community
I will love my black neighbors the same
as my white ones
what is this what stupidity is this
they're holding their hands up like
they're in praise to God they're
praising the woke ideology this is what
this is where the Bible warns of
idolatry and taking anything before God
and making it a God and they are making
this ideology their God and everything
about them and they are they this will
disappoint them this will leave them
empty they will never be satisfied by it
you'll have no connection to any greater
spiritual being nothing nothing they'll
have nothing but emptiness and misery
which is what they have and hate which
is what they have for their own skin
color because they're convinced that
just being white that they're already
bad to black people sad this is so and
you have to go and you have to pray to
the black lives matter gods that are
milking you for money that you're not
gonna that you're gonna treat black
people the same when you do this
you don't end up treating black people
the same because now every time you look
at a black person you're thinking you
have to kiss their ass you're not even
treating them even if they're not a nice
person no you're just like I'm sorry I'm
sorry it's the truth though I remember
going through this and there'd be a
black guy walking up down the street and
I have to be like how are you good to
see you good to see you doing good I
treat everybody the same still no but I
remember I'm just joking but I remember
feeling different like you you felt like
you had to be nicer because they also
you you were convinced that this is this
is what they did to people though I
don't know I'm just no no I remember
having a couple of moments of feeling
that way and then being and then even
having that internal conversation like
no I'm not letting this affect me
treating everybody the same if I'm in a
bad mood nobody's getting a hello if I'm
in a good mood everybody's getting a
smile I don't give a about your
skin color I don't and I never did and I
was raised not to notice people for that
I was raised to notice people for How
They Carried themselves and what the
content of their character was and I'm
sticking with it and they can pound this
there's things now that like I won't do
business with people if they believe
certain stuff like if they believe in
Black lives matter still they hate Tate
I just like I won't like let you work
for me because I just know you're a
weak-minded person and you'll turn on
somebody if the News tells you to or
you're just your your brain you're not
as you don't you don't think for
yourself yeah when I was at um so why
would I work with you when I was at um
it's actually a good thing when I worked
out easy red flags when I worked at
Wayfair I was going through uh resumes
for our semester-long intern and one of
them sent over their portfolios in the
creative department and one of them sent
over a whole portfolio of loaded with
woke I just pushed right by it
really right by I'm not dealing with
that nope nah man it's funny how
often people like have to like portray
that they're woke to and in reality
they're they're just like they're not
I've had multiple business calls where
I'm like I say some and they're
like oh yeah like that's facts but like
on social media it's the opposite or
their company profile it's all
all right thank you so much for watching
that cut that that was disgusting and
that embarrasses me as a mother that
that's how you act in public
[Music]